one of the most important things you can
do before you start an IV or draw blood
is to properly anchor the vein Before
You Stick It anchoring a vein will help
prevent it from moving or rolling as you
go to penetrate the skin with the needle
and in this video I'm going to
demonstrate how to Anchor veins so first
of all why do nurses and phlebotomists
and other Healthcare professionals need
to Anchor veins before every stick well
the biggest reason is because veins are
actually quite mobile and whenever you
go to take the needle and actually
penetrate that skin it can cause that
vein to roll to the side or move to the
side which causes you to miss the vein
and I know that most patients aren't
going to have visible veins like this
however in my videos I like to use veins
that are like this because it helps you
to visually understand what's going on
Under the Skin now you may have heard of
the expression rolling veins or hear
another nurse say well the vein rolled
on me and what that just means is that
the vein moved it doesn't necessarily
mean that the vein rolled around Brown
on its axis it's really just an
expression that we use to describe
whenever this happens now what can cause
a vein to move or roll well there are
several reasons this can happen one
reason is that the patient actually
shifts or moves their body suddenly
especially if they're confused or afraid
of needles so it's always important to
instruct the patient to remain still in
addition some patient populations can
experience mobile veins more than others
particularly older adults as a patient
ages veins skin and surrounding tissue
can lose elasticity and then lastly some
veins move due to their location for
example veins on the hand tend to be
more superficial and have less fat and
other structures around to help keep
them in place whereas veins in the
cubital fossa region tend to be a bit
more stable due to the surrounding
muscle tissue however remember you
always want to Anchor every vein before
you stick it so before anchoring veins
you always want to perform hand hygiene
next you want to palpate for a van need
to penetrate ideally go for a straight
vein that is easily visible properly
prepare the site and follow your
facilities protocols or anchoring veins
now there are two important steps that
you want to follow whenever you're
anchoring any vein the first step is to
create some tension on that vein you do
this by having the patient either
straighten or bend the extremity to
naturally stretch that vein out to
illustrate this just picture a piece of
string when the string is just sitting
there it can move in almost any
direction however when I apply tension
to the string it loses much of its
Mobility so let's say that you're
drawing blood or started in an IV from a
vein in the cubital fossa area which is
found on the front of the elbow you
could extend and support the patient's
elbow to apply tension to the veins now
if you're using the hand you might want
the patient to make a fist and gently
bend the area to add tension however if
you're drawing blood like for lab work
be sure the patient doesn't pump their
fists or squeeze too hard because this
could alter the potassium calcium lab
results the second important step in
anchoring a vein is to position the
thumb of your non-dominant hand around
one to two inches below the insertion
side and then pull the skin down and
hold the vein in place this will add
even more stability to prevent excessive
movement of that vein and a key point to
this step here is while you're holding
the skin taut and applying light
pressure with your thumb over the vein
you're also using the rest of your
fingers and hand to hold the extremity
steady as you penetrate with the needle
and once you've performed all the
necessary steps you're ready to stick
another technique that some people use
to help anchor that vein is called the C
hold or the C technique with this
technique you use the index finger and
thumb to stretch the skin taut and to
hold the vein in place as you stick now
this technique also works to Anchor
veins however the newest guidelines
recommend not using this method because
there's a risk of a needle injury to the
healthcare worker in addition when you
use the index finger in the Thumb in
this position it makes it a bit harder
to hold the extremity steady with the
rest of your hand in the thumb and green
technique I discussed at the beginning
it makes it much easier to grasp the
limb and hold it steady so as a quick
comparison you can see how both methods
can anchor the vein in place however the
thumb anchoring technique is generally
considered safer since the thumb is
under and not above the needle okay so
that wraps up this video on how to
Anchor veins and if you'd like to watch
more videos on how to start IVs and
other IV tips you can access the link in
the YouTube description below